really bizarre story just happened here
in my state of Tennessee
Apple just made history
by welcoming in their new twins these
twins are biologically not theirs
biologically adopted but they weren't
adopted in the normal way they were
adopted as Frozen embryos as Frozen
embryos that were conceived in 1992.
so these babies were conceived in 1992
put in a freezer for 30 years and then
this couple in Tennessee adopted the
embryos and gave birth to them
they are both these little children are
the couple's youngest kids and oldest
kids these little babies are
about as old as I am actually
even though they're little babies and
the whole thing is really really strange
the main takeaway here I think
people are going to be debating the uh
bioethics of uh embryo adoption
and I I don't really know exactly what
to think of embryo adoption in a way it
seems quite wrong because you're
separating the procreative act from the
conjugal Act
uh although it's not obviously was not
the couple that did this but the couple
is involved in the implantation and so
that seems to me bioethically dubious
but on the other hand you've got these
Frozen people that are just Frozen in
perpetuity and then a couple comes in
and says we're gonna we're gonna
actually allow you guys to have life and
not just leave you Frozen in perpetuity
that seems like a wonderful thing and so
everyone's going to be focused on the
bioethics of is embryo adoption okay is
it not okay are there questions about it
whatever to me that's a secondary point
I don't have an answer on that point yet
though I am somewhat cautious about it
the real
takeaway here I think is that IVF is
just absolutely awful it's just
absolutely unacceptable I know a lot of
people have used IVF I know a lot of
people have been tricked into using IVF
and I know a lot of people are grateful
to IVF because there are children who
are walking around today exist because
of IVF and and so I'm I'm not asking you
to you know regret your children or
something like that obviously the kids
are a good end and sometimes people
engage in these things unwittingly and
out of desperation out of ignorance but
good Ends don't justify immoral means
and I think the more we look into IVF
it's so clear this is immoral just look
at those two little kids
those little kids are real kids they're
real people
and they've been real people for 30
years in a in this Frozen stasis in a
freezer okay
and there are lots and lots and lots of
people like this and that is the result
it is frankly the inevitable result of a
regime that tolerates in vitro
fertilization
and so if those two little kids are real
people
then all those embryos and all those
freezers are real people too
and for every two little kids they get
born and adopted 30 years later think of
all the people think of all the souls
they're in those freezers that is just
unacceptable and no no desire to resolve
infertility which often they're not in
all cases but but often can be resolved
in other ways that are not so
bioethically compromised
but that is that is not those are real
kids okay if you doubted before that the
the souls on Ice were real people those
are real kids and so it's Gotta It's
gotta lead us back to thinking okay
why were these kids allowed to be in a
freezer for 30 years to begin with and
and should we really allow that to
persist I don't think so right now head
on over to geniusell.com what if I told
you that you could make those Fine Lines
forehead wrinkles dark spots even under
eye bags disappear sounds too good to be
true right well it's not when you make
genucel skin care a part of your daily
routine genucel has sold over 1 million
products to both men and women and the
reviews speak for themselves Samantha
writes quote I love geniusell skin care
I've used it all over my face under my
eyes and it cleared up the dry flakiness
and even reduced my forehead lines
someone even asked if I had had work
done geniusell uses a proprietary base
with clinical levels of Botanical
extracts which come together to yield
amazing results geniusell products are
natural cruelty free and made in the USA
take advantage of geniusell's early
Black Friday sale going on right now you
can get their most popular products
package for over 70 percent off you'll
get two months worth of their best
sellers plus their hyaluronic acid serum
free with your purchase take advantage
of this amazing deal now by going to
geniusell.com Knowles and use code
Knolls for an extra 10 off that is
genucel.com Knowles genucel.com Knowles
speaking of new people in our country
there is a there is a bill up that not a
lot of people are talking about because
I think that the liberal establishment
and the Swiss Republicans would rather
just get this thing passed in the dead
of night not have anybody talk about it
but it's a big problem it's called The
Eagle act the eagle Act is a green card
giveaway for Democrats and Fortune 500
CEOs
this is being peddled by the Democrats
but eight Republicans have co-sponsored
the bill
this includes representative Tom emmer
who unfortunately accidentally because
one guy voted incorrectly mistakenly I
became the the whip for the Republicans
beating out Jim Banks who's actually a
conservative but you got eight
Republicans co-sponsoring this bill and
and what it does is it supercharges uh
citizenship incentives for Indians and
Chinese Nationals
to take Fortune 500 White Collar careers
over Americans over Americans who have
gone to college who have probably taken
out a lot of debt maybe quarter million
dollars maybe more than a quarter
million dollars in debt now immigrants
are going to get a faster track to that
and who wins
Democrats win because immigrants are
much more likely to vote for Democrats I
know I know the Republicans always say
well the immigrants they're they're
Republicans they just don't know it yet
uh yeah maybe we're still waiting on
that that still hasn't really quite
happened in certain small localities
sometimes immigrants break a little bit
for republicans and usually that's just
with the help of the Cubans who happen
to be extremely conservative but
generally speaking no the immigrants
vote for Democrats
and so it's a big win for the Democrats
electorally it's a big win for the big
corporations and for the Chamber of
Commerce that doesn't care about
anything really other than just boosting
its profit margins a little bit but it's
a big loss for the country okay the the
country has a responsibility politicians
have a responsibility to prioritize the
citizens of the country they have a
responsibility to prioritize their
constituents over
foreigners over
very wealthy influential CEOs
over
over all sorts of other vested interests
okay over the Democrats trying to rig
the elections they have a responsibility
to Americans okay a country is about
more than just GDP a country is about
more than just quarterly profits from a
handful of Corporations a country is
about more than just an idea meaning
that the country is really just an idea
of floating around the whole globe no
country is a real place with real people
with real borders with real geography
with real Traditions with a real way of
life okay and and uh it shows you how
tough this issue is because even the
Republicans
totally swish on immigration the vast
majority of Americans want to
drastically reduce all immigration legal
and illegal because it's just insanely
High three million people a year is just
crazy it's the largest movement of human
beings ever in recorded history over the
last 60 years into the United States and
so
the problem is the Democrats want much
much more of it because it gives them an
advantage and the Republicans
also kind of want more of it because
their donors demand it
and so what you're left with is the
toughest immigration position that we
get even from the most hard-line
immigration Hawks at the real top level
of politics is illegal bad legal good
illegal immigration is bad but legal
immigration is good so what do they do
they just changed a law to flood the
country with legal immigrants but the
effect of disruption of problems of
assimilation of suppressing wages of
taking jobs it's all the same right you
get the exact same
issue there
and so what are we going to do about it
it just shows you when even a republican
when even a conservative wants to go in
and fight the system he's got to fight a
lot more than just Joe Biden and some
Democrats he's got to fight the whole
system
all right the rest of the show continues
now we have a very good friend of mine
coming on the show today
to talk about a new documentary and one
of the biggest biggest political issues
in America where probably some of the
most important political fights are
taking place that would be at the
schools
the rest of the show continues now if
you are not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]